vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
ministres la terre d'Arménie brûle et
nous regardons ailleurs
depuis l'automne 2020 l'Arménie est en
état de siège depuis l'invasion de
l'enclave arménienne Larzac par l'armée
d'Azerbaïdjan soutenu par la Turquie qui
s'en sert comme avant garde pour
poursuivre et achever l'éradication du
peuple arménien entamé en 1915 entre les
épisodes de guerre civile qui a déjà
fait 5000 morts et 15000 blessés en
trois ans c'est un véritable blocus
orchestré par l'Azerbaïdjan pour
empêcher les vivres et les médicaments
d'arriver jusque dans l'enclave
arménienne les seuls qu'il est droit de
passage sont les Arméniens qui fuient la
guerre la famine et la misère mais ils
n'ont droit qu'à un aller simple
l'Azerbaïdjan comptant sur le départ des
120 000 Arméniens restants pour poser
définitivement son joug sur ce
territoire
et ce n'est qu'une première étape pour
rayer de la carte cette terre chrétienne
quelle Arménie la plus ancienne du monde
aujourd'hui encerclé par l'expansion
musulmane depuis nos villes des
Hauts-de-Seine qui accueillent une forte
communauté d'origine arménienne nous
envoyons des vives des médicaments et
aussi des médecins en partenariat avec
lumière française
ainsi nous essayons de forcer le blocus
mais qu'attend le gouvernement au-delà
des messages d'amitié pour demander le
respect des règles internationales et du
droit des peuples l'Arménie ce petit
pays porte les mêmes valeurs que les
nôtres alors c'est vrai que l'Arménie ce
n'est pas l'Ukraine on y trouve ni
pétrole ni gaz contrairement à
l'Azerbaïdjan l'Arménie n'a rien hormis
sa foi et son courage ma question madame
la ministre et donc de savoir si la
France est prête à mobiliser les mêmes
moyens diplomatiques voire militaire
qu'on l'a fait pour l'Ukraine pour
défendre en Arménie un peuple amis qui
est en train de mourir merci
[Musique]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et les
affaires étrangères madame Colonna merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Balzac merci de votre question
car il permet de rappeler que depuis le
premier jour c'est-à-dire depuis le 12
décembre la France dénonce le blocage du
corridor de latin par l'Azerbaïdjan et
ses conséquences tentent économiques
humanitaires en effet la population
depuis cette date ne peut plus circuler
librement les vivre arrivent
de façon parcimonieuse et grâce au
Comité international de la Croix-Rouge
que la France aide monsieur le sénateur
ainsi que ses partenaires de l'Union
européenne alors oui cette situation ne
peut plus durer la libre circulation
doit être rétablie sans tarder et
l'approvisionnement des populations du
haut-karaba doit être mieux assurée
d'abord parce que c'est le droit et je
l'ai dit ici je veux le rappeler la Cour
internationale de justice c'est prononcé
par référé il y a quelques semaines et
ensuite parce que ce blocage alimente
les tensions éloignent les perspectives
de règlement politique qui est le seul
possible donc un accord de paix que nous
recherchons et que l'Arménie recherche
monsieur sénateur avec son voisin je
prévois de me rendre à Baco et à Erevan
Coran avril pour porter ce message pour
rappeler la nécessité d'une solution
politique pour rappeler la nécessité
d'abord du ccfeu auquel les deux parties
se sont engagés et pour souligner que
les menaces d'emploi de la force sont
inacceptables je le redis monsieur le
sénateur nous sommes déterminés je suis
déterminé et la France agit elle ne
regarde pas ailleurs elle agit elle ne
parle pas je vous remercie